it's still working that last one but why
not press forward right
why not
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by david harbour
he's an emmy and tony award-nominated
actor perhaps best well known for his
portrayal of jim hopper and the netflix
mega hit series stranger things
his latest though is the highly
anticipated marvel studios action spy
thriller black widow which is set to hit
theaters in disney plus premiere access
on july 9th
david harbor welcome to the show thank
you for having me i think
yeah what is going through your mind
right now prepare for this adventure
concerned
i'm very concerned i was uh walking over
here and i
i wasn't eating a lot today you know i
was preparing my stomach for this and
then i decided to have a really big
chocolate chip cookie
right before i got here which i think
was a terrible idea for hot sauces
so i'm i'm kind of nervous but we'll see
how this goes
oh see there goes the alarm that's it
everybody out of the building
can't do the wing challenge
[Music]
conserve energy conserve energy turn off
those cameras then
this is the one this is the one okay
[Music]
now that's not bad there's no problem
man
i got this
[Music]
so in black widow you play the role of
alexis shazdakov a russian counterpart
to captain america who's hilariously
void of the conventional superhero
virtues
and i'm curious how do you as an actor
think about
the traits that make a heroic character
a hero
versus the weaker qualities that make
them human that's an interesting
question um
i guess i'm always interested in flawed
characters much more than i am incapable
characters
the people that i tend i tend to fall in
love with people or my heart goes out to
people who are
i find beauty in people's flaws i find
beauty and their inadequacies
and i think true like love and when you
think about someone and sort of obsess
about them it's because of their frailty
i think it's what
binds us and like alexi has a lot of
that
you know his neediness and his remorse
comes out in this very bombastic
egotistical way where a lot of people
that feel less than
sort of act big like they're big
big shots and so i found that really
charming about him i just find a lot of
these
little you know moments within him that
are kind of as you say weaknesses or
flaws i think that's what i
always start with and then the
superpowers kind of take care of
themselves you know like
i gotta jump 40 feet in the air and
there's a guy with a wire who like pulls
me up so that's
you know that's kind of easy
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
okay i see where we're headed
but i'm good with this so i've heard you
talk about playing hamlet at 19 in a way
that sort of feels like
a fever dream of angst and artistic
expression i'm curious
what do you think what do you think is
the best on-ramp to shakespeare for
people watching who've sworn off the
works after reading macbeth in 10th
grade
that's great an on-ramp to shakespeare i
love that
car i don't know you know i mean i'll
tell you my personal connection to
shakespeare i don't know
i wonder how it holds up but when i was
in eighth grade
[Music]
a buddy of mine dragged me to see henry
v that kenneth branagh
directed and starred in and that like
changed my life and changed my
experience in relationship to
shakespeare and it really was my
on-ramp to shakespeare i didn't know
much about shakespeare except as you say
like reading romeo and juliet when i was
in
high school and hating it like everybody
else so this really changed my something
about the swelling music and
you know derek jacoby comes out with a
match in the beginning and lights i mean
it's just really
it's very well done so i would i'd
recommend that one and then you once
said
that as a young actor you're broken into
two types a romeo and a mercutio
can you break that down and which one
are you i mean i'm definitely a
mercutio and i guess this is my
relationship to film in general there's
just dudes that are just good looking
and they sort of they're kind of the
popular kids like i was never really
that popular in high school there's that
table
of like guys who like played football
and there's that table in the actor
world
too where they just look great they're
always kind of in shape
and they just show up on film really
well and then there's guys like me who
like you take a picture of them and
they're weird they have like one eye
open
kind of and like a little bit of a
double chin and i've always been that
way but
you use that freak in you to bring
something special
because things don't come as easily to
you but i do think in
in general you tend to find those actors
along the way and you can spot them and
you can be like oh hey man you're my
fellow weirdo my fellow mercutio
catches up with you a little bit oh yeah
it does kind of hit you a little bit
later though
yeah yeah i'm okay though this is only
number three though
of 10. okay
base my confidence here
what's the most harrowing experience you
had as a young man and member of an
underground new york city poker club
like did you ever
see oh my god how do you know did you
actually
research thank you play together no no
no i i wish i wish did you ever see like
a brazen
armed robbery attempt or like played an
especially high stakes game or anything
like that
yeah i explained some high sick game i
never saw go down one of the reasons
those places got shut down because they
were sort of sanctioned
i mean under the table by the cops for a
long time and then what happened was
guys would break it and the guy broke in
i guess a couple guys broke in with
shotguns and just accidentally one of
them went off and shot
an old guy it's not as romantic as you
think it is like
like actually that movie rounders right
that's like what's in my head
those guys who wrote that movie i used
to play with and i know the guy who is
teddy kgb
and he does not look like john malkovich
he looks like a kind of dumpy like
little dude but yeah there was a real
real beautiful moment in the underground
poker scene in new york that
i wish lasted forever
i didn't know you'd be asking me like
real questions
[Laughter]
this is what is this hot ones barbacoa
okay
[Music]
almost like a pleasant downshift from
the last one there's a different quality
in the hotness right
that's there's no measure of that but
this one feels more peppery and this
one's
more like i don't know like a just
different quality yeah like a morning
fog
kind of spice or something exactly a
morning fog type of spice
yes so there'd be anarchy in the
comments if we didn't take a wing to
discuss stranger things the pop culture
phenomenon that's won more than
60 major awards since premiering in
2016.
wow why did you call the buyer's family
dog chester one of the worst actors
oh my god i hated that [ __ ] dog i
hated that [ __ ] knockover
take after take it would like wander off
or do something and then i just remember
the trainer
like on the sidelines going come on
we gotta make our money we gotta make
our money
um yeah i walked up to them and i was
like you know
the buyer should probably have that dog
put to sleep
we never talk about it the whole rest of
the show but they just wind up not
having a dog
the dog's gonna dwell on there you
should find it upside down though in one
of these future seasons
there he went he crawled through the
tree and then and working with winona
i've heard you say that
sometimes to get into the hopper
character you'll you'll get angry and
she'll intuitively go there with you
what does that actually like mean or
look like on set
for acting to happen and for it to
resonate in a real way like i think the
reason why you go watch a movie and
you'll be like ooh that was good
or like that's cheesy it doesn't do
anything for you
it's because like actually drama happens
the only way drama happens
is if two people actually experience
something
real together so in a sense like
you have to bleed a little bit and like
you know
the construct of this is very heady but
the construct of character love petty
okay okay okay i've been doing so much
press where it's just like
you know who would win in a fight with
captain america i'm like i'm like do i
talk about real stuff i'm so confused
right now okay okay i won't apologize so
the um
the construct of character exists only
in on the page and in your mind
and in the structure of the piece what
exists on the screen
is david and winona theoretically at its
best
dramatically is when david and winona
are actually mad at each other
a lot of work nowadays i feel like
people don't like that as much they
everybody wants
you know everybody get along and i feel
like there's a lot of there's some
danger
in that interaction and so what i find
with winona
she knows that beauty comes from mess
the lotus grows from the mud right so
let's sling some mud at each other she's
very willing to do that and it's
i've found it sort of hard harder and
harder
in a certain way to find people who are
willing to do that
[Music]
pineapple and ginger all right
[Music]
this one's good i like this one i like
the ginger a little pineapple ginger
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh that's good all right david while you
enjoy that wing we have recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham we're do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context
so we'll pull up the picture on the mind
wow just tell us a bigger story
do you have a favorite penguin fun fact
or observation about
wildlife in the arctic i got a i got a
penguin fun fact
penguins are very necessary i love
penguins they're very necessary
for the environment i love and dark sky
i love penguin they want to protect the
pants
they're disgusting creatures they are
absolutely disgusting because when you
go on these
antarctic glaciers and you see penguins
it's
nothing but [ __ ] and blood there was
another really cool thing about penguins
when so they have these things down
there in antarctica called leopard seals
do you know what these are they're
they're vicious vicious so they're like
there was one that
you know they grow like 12 15 feet long
these things
and they eat penguins and we were on one
of these glaciers walking around
and literally from the ocean like 20
feet away from
this leopard seal just came out of the
ocean
like the biggest thing i've ever seen
looked around guys
and then proceeded to puke up a uh
penguin skeleton
and then like slither back and see it
going it's like
terrifying terrifying
[Music]
what are we on number six we're on
number six oh i'm kind of enjoying this
tiki hot masala
yeah that's good that's good we started
we're starting to get there yep
that's good yeah we're not messing
around anymore
no we're going forward it's not starting
to happen now i see why people are so
upset about this show
so elizabeth olsen who was actually on
the show recently she did a semester at
the moscow art theater school
when i talked to her if she had like a
preference between the stanislavski
method or the
check off organic performance and i've
heard you likewise talk about
russian influence is there a playwright
or a theater practitioner that
you think informed your technique or
process more than others
for me it's like lee strasbourg or bust
like i'm a devotee
he's american method it's the actor's
studio where
lee strasberg taught everybody's
relationship to things is different so
the literal relationship is not very
important what's important is the
metaphoric relationship and that
is very much the american method it's
not about actually like
being the character because you can't
it's about your metaphoric relationship
acting as if you're the character but
yeah it was very much strasbourg
what came out of the group theater
probably the greatest theater of
america and then like lee strasberg sort
of took it in this other direction where
they all
argued with him and hated him and fell
out but i think what he was doing
you know through the 60s and 70s was
just the is just the best acting
training there is
[Music]
i'm starting to feel it like leave its
thing on my tongue though there's a
cumulative yeah here we go
[Music]
okay a little more serious this one
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
wow i've been drunk in like uh
15 years when i'm starting to feel it
gets trippy good wait a little bit it's
trippy
yeah okay so growing up in white plains
i know that you connected with the
outcasts your
dnd and video games and graphic novels
what are the necessary components for
the perfect dungeons and dragons party
um oh god the necessary components i
mean i guess you have to have
like a good party of people and that
means a mix like you need
people that are gonna play by the rules
and then you need people that are gonna
break the rules and be horrible and
you know not do what you tell them to do
if you have too many
good students it's just not that fun
and if you have too many rule breakers
you can't get anything done and nothing
moves you can't have any fights it's all
just like sitting around
looking at curios in some shop or
something and then you do need like
an indefinite amount of time you need
just like a day
where there's no limits you can go to
like six in the morning
and just like dig in like any degraded
activity like poker or whatever like you
want to get that sweet spot
where you feel like you should be doing
something else but nobody knows you're
doing it still
so you can just get lost in the
degradation that's part of the joy
yeah that's good well
this next one should we go for number
three this is the bomb
this is the one
don't psych yourself out okay
[Music]
child's play
yeah you breathe differently without you
it affects your respiration and i don't
think it ever goes back
i think forever forever changed over
here david wow
i'll breathe like this for the rest of
my life god that's what's happening damn
i mean yeah well it's serious
um oh yeah it's still happening it'll
grow
full it just yeah yeah i like that i
like that unfolds i like that
wow oh yeah oh wow wow wow
okay ask me more questions so i can show
you talking
i've seen you post uh pictures of
barrico ham
in spain and then you were posted
prosciutto
in uh venice what is your mount rushmore
your top four cured meats of all time
[Music]
your top four cured meats of all time
wow god damn that is the hardest
question i've ever been asked and you
saved it until we're almost done
with the hottest sauces i knew you get
harder as you go
top four cured meats i can't even think
of a single cured meat right now
i mean i mean like i can't even think of
a single one like
there was a pepperoni pizza i had like a
million years ago that i remember was
nice
ah this is still happening it's still
unfolding i haven't even taken a second
bite yet
is there a dive bar or restaurant spot
that you missed the most thinking back
about your inglorious days in the east
village
oh yeah god yes i can have one more bite
of this just because i'm
then i'm going into crazy right come on
what are we gonna do die maybe
um yeah i got one oh man i got some good
ones okay
oh my god oh my god
okay on on avenue a
i lived on 12th street between a and b
and so on avenue a
between 12th and 13th there was a place
called karova milk bar
corrova milk bar used to make milk
drinks
that were that were a very alcoholic
and they were all based on this is
horrible but this is the east village we
can go there right yeah let's go
they're all based on on dead like
child stars or whatever i used to love
that plate
and they would play clockwork orange in
black light
it was a horrible place those are the
days
those are the days in manhattan it was
also yeah i mean that was back when we
were still we were still dark you know
we weren't the mall we are today
oh so good
i'm very proud of myself i have to say
i'm very i really did not think
i was going to be okay with any of this
and it seems like you're downright
enjoying it i am kind of enjoying it
this is actually a lot of fun
[Music]
it's still working that last one but why
not press forward right
why not where else do we have to be
okay this one is the scorpion disco the
scorpion
those of you keeping score i think that
was a bar in the east village i think
[Music]
still a labor still intense
no it's really hurting what's your best
advice for how to care for white's tree
frogs as
pets you once said in a q a with
playbill that
you're very passionate about keeping and
breeding them as a child
oh my god you do your research not only
do you cook
amazing wings but you do your research
yes okay i love white street frogs
australian white street frogs
i build your own terrarium i build my
own terrariums
oh yeah i wanted them to breed the only
way a white street frog will have sex
is if they're rained on for 20 hours a
day
and if they have a foot of water so
i had to make a terrarium with a sump
pump and
rain pipes and it would rain on them for
20 hours a day and they still didn't
have sex because i guess they have to
like each other too
all right david what are you doing
shaking that
up
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last one
you don't have to
if you don't want to oh but don't do
that oh you're insane
yeah it's affecting my whole i like it
i seriously haven't like i'm sober for a
long time
yeah and that's been drunk for a long
time in this kind of it's
bringing you back yeah
i feel like a little bit like out of
control yeah not sure what i'll do next
oh oh my lips
[Music]
come on baby here we go
[Music]
all right man let's do it right cheers
david hey
cheers cheers huh
[Music]
i love on the super hots how you kind of
smile and laugh your way in
it's just so crazy
[Music]
oh oh wow
[Music]
but thankfully david we've reached the
conclusion
of our spicy food adventure today and
just one more question for you
you know we've covered a lot of ground
from broadway to frogs
to marvel and what i really like about
you is that you're so honest about the
journey so honest about the highs the
lows
the rejection and the pain and the
humiliation that can come with pursuing
a career in acting
so now with your blood slowly roasting
inside of you
your tongue and brain on fire i'm
curious
what words of enlightenment or caution
do you have to other creative young
people
who are interested in a calling in the
arts
i remember hearing this when i was
coming through and i would hear
actors come speak to you at college or
whatever and they'd go only do it if you
have to do it and i'd go like i will
never
say that when i become an actor because
even if you want to do it you should try
it
and now i feel like i say it all the
time only do if you have to do it
because there is
i feel like i i could have had a very
happy simple life
doing all kinds of other things but at
the time
i just couldn't imagine myself doing
anything else
only do it because you need to do it not
because you want to be famous
do it because you have something to
express and then
just be tenacious you don't even have to
be that good
you just gotta like stick with it
and speaking of sticking with it working
your
way through the gauntlet the hot ones
gauntlet
came in here with mixed confidence
coming through the other side
dominating the board and look at you
david harbor
taking on hot ones and living to tell
the tale now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
what what
is that this is the confessional you get
me drunk on hot swings and you
okay hey uh i got uh
some movie on hbo max directed by
soderberg called no
sun move which i'm very excited about
but of course the big one is go see
black widow marvel suit as black widow
in theaters and on disney plus
july 9th good job david
good job thanks guys
wow
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans checking in with some very
exciting first week feast news
now when i'm not over here choking down
chicken wings on hot ones
i happen to be a huge pizza guy sicilian
neopolitan deep dish dollar slice
frozen pizza i love it all which is why
i'm excited to announce that first we
feast has a brand new show
pizza wars where pizza master nicole
russell takes on contenders in a battle
royale of different pizza styles
i'm on there judging the deep dish
episode naturally but the show has other
great guests as well including
buddies like babish and frank pinello
but that's enough chit chat let's let
the sizzle reel do the talking
alright roll the tape
[Music]
the misconception is that if you get a
lot it's good
bite for bite this is the best eating
experience i've ever had on one of these
things
my opponents and i will be taking on a
new piece of theme challenge
every episode i wish that i could give
you both trophies but they only gave me
one do you guys have an extra
they don't have an extra don't get it
twisted this is a competition
and i want to win but i'm also here to
catch up with a few of my friends
i couldn't have done this episode with
nobody else
to learn some new tricks to use at home
you gotta slice the garlic thin
so thin that it liquefies in the pan no
no thank you for that
thank you nona and eat a whole bunch of
pizza
oh
so get ready people peace awards is
[Music]
coming
you